bien
un día histórico juba la capital de
sudán del sur acogió la firma de un
acuerdo de paz entre el gobierno de
transición de sudán y los cinco
principales grupos rebeldes armados del
país
y la única forma de lograr la
estabilidad política y económica de
nuestro país pasa por un acuerdo de paz
integral a través de un proceso como el
que comenzamos hoy
los rebeldes sudaneses tendrán
representación política en un país que
durante 30 años estuvo gobernado por
omar al-bashir depuesto en abril de 2019
por un golpe militar
[Música]
el mar mediterráneo tiene un nuevo barco
de rescate su nombre louis michel un
homenaje a la célebre anarquista
francesa del siglo 19 la financiación
obra de banks y el conocido y al mismo
tiempo anónimo artista urbano británico
louis michel está operado por la ong
alemanas y watch en 2019 banks y
contacto con la activista alemana pjak
lema le ofreció sus obras para conseguir
financiación que le pensó que era una
broma hoy es la capitana de un barco en
el que no faltan representaciones del
artista
[Música]
felicidad entre los aficionados al
ciclismo el 29 de agosto regreso el tour
de francia con dos meses de retraso es
la edición 107 que será recordada por
celebrarse en plena pandemia a pesar del
virus los aficionados no han dudado en
acudir a apoyar a sus ídolos
por supuesto apoyamos al equipo y nuevos
porque tenemos al gun bernal en ese
equipo vamos a defender nuestro último
título del tour de francia y estamos
felices de estar aquí para apoyarlos
una victoria a la de gun bernal que le
convirtió en 2019 en el primer
latinoamericano en ganar el tour de
francia
[Música]
la ciencia al rescate de los bosques
investigadores alemanes tratan de
contrarrestar las consecuencias del
cambio climático lo hacen con la
plantación de árboles mediterráneos y el
cambio climático provocado por el hombre
aumentará las temperaturas y las sequías
en las próximas décadas en toda alemania
estamos viendo problemas con las aguas
subterráneas por lo tanto tenemos que
adaptar nuestros bosques alemanes
el experimento ya está cosechando éxitos
tras plantar roble pubescente en el
bosque de la ciudad de frankfurt estos
árboles han sobrevivido durante tres
veranos secos sin sufrir ningún daño se
espera que en 100 años el clima de
alemania sea como el que hoy hay en el
sur de francia
[Música]
el futuro está cada vez más cerca en
japon un coche consiguió volar durante 4
minutos es el automóvil volador más
pequeño del mundo y cabe en el
estacionamiento de dos coches se espera
que en 2023 este prototipo pueda echar
el vuelo de forma comercial